good evening to everybody
first of all i'm presenting myself
i am roberto chiarle
an associate professor at harvard
medical school and
a research
assistant at the boston children's
hospital
and um i'm going to talk tonight to you
about
uh some
recent advances that we made in our lab
about novel therapies that
can be used potentially in the future to
target
arc mutated in particular alk rearranged
cancers and i would like also to thank
bioconference live to
train me this opportunity to present my
work in front of
you as an audience even if i don't see
you as an audience i will be very happy
to present so
the
work that i'm presenting tonight
starts with the idea of boosting cancer
immunotherapy for a specific type of
tumors and
as you might know
the cancer
immunotherapy relies on the recognition
by the immune system of cancer cells and
this recognition is a very long process
that requires several steps
and in these slides
there are summarized some of the key
steps
according to this um
this slide there are like seven steps
but they they can be a little bit more
but in any case the the very first step
uh he starts with the release
here in point one from the with the
release
of uh antigens specific from cancer
cells and typically cancer cells they
can have a specific antigens uh either
because they carry chromosomal
translocations or because they
have
somatic point mutation in protein that
turned out to be antigenic can be
recognized by the new system
has antigens
so this is the first phase in which a
dying cancer cell is kind of releasing
antigens that are normal for the immune
system and they can be captured and this
is phase two they can be captured by the
self
presenting as specialized cells that
present the the antigen typically
dendritic cells and this uh dendritic
cells for uh
several type of macrophage then can
eventually migrate to lymph nodes and
here is point number three in which
after migration to lymph nodes at that
point there is a uh the real um
happening of the immune reaction in
which presenting cells they carry on the
antigen and present
to t cells in the lymph nodes and also b
cells of course so there is a strong
interaction between presenting cells b
and t cells and also other cell type
like t-rex cells th17 cells
in in the lymph node where the immune
reaction really takes place
um after the antigen is presented by the
specific presenting cells and the t
cells or pieces are primed to recognize
the antigen then the next phase is
trafficking we are talking mainly on t
cells because
uh cancer recognition is made mostly by
by t cells but i mean of course also
obeses are important but
most of them
can anti-cancer activity of the immune
system goes through diesels so in in the
stage four of this immune
immune
reaction now these thesis that have been
primed to recognize specifically cancer
antigen
released by the cancer cells now they go
back to the blood vessels they go back
in trafficking and
they
basically
move around the entire body and then
eventually they can
infiltrate inside the tumors and there
is phase five in which um t cells they
leave the bloodstream and then they
infiltrate the tumor and there in the
tumor site so this is phase six and
seven basically there is a
first step of recognition of
the t cells the prime t cells in the
lymph node now recognize the antigen the
same antigen now presented of the cancer
cells and finally if everything goes
fine
finally there is a the last step that is
uh the killing process which is the the
ultimate goal of the immune system
against cancer so
you see is a very long process that
requires a lot of components and you see
highlighted in in green and and in red
a lot of factors that can affect this
this process either by stimulate and
increase the efficacy of the
presentation and priming and migration
of these cells and diesel recognition of
the cancer cells but there are also
i would say an equal amount of factors
that
inhibit this this process and all these
factors typically are inhibitory factors
that work in the immune system to
to block or or prevent
an exaggerated new response against the
bacterial viral antigen so
basically you see there is a a long list
of
a pro
cancer factor and anti-cancer factor
that can affect the balance of this
entire system
why and how we can manipulate the the
immune system to target cancer cells so
of course
cancer vaccine or cancer vaccination is
a is a topic very important in the past
i would say three to four decades maybe
even even more uh in the battle against
cancer and uh there have been
several
uh experimental way to to
use and exploit the immune system to
recognize better than it does naturally
the
the cancer cells and eventually
helping in the killing and elimination
of the tumor cells so you see here in
this recent review
summarize the most
important i would say most effective way
to target cancer cells that have been
developed throughout the year
so
there have been a vaccine
trying to use
irradiated cytokine releasing
cytokine releasing the tumor cells in
which the cancer said they release both
the cytokines and antigens or also
dendritic cells that can be primed to
present antigen to the immune system and
these cells they can be
infused into the patient to
activate the dendritic cells with
specific antigens that are of course
tumor antigen and this priming
results in inactivation of
tumor-specific cd4 and cd8 t cells that
are the same cells that eventually
reciculate and find the tumor and kill
it
another way is to
exploit in situ the release of
antigens by cancer cell through either
apoptosis or through other way to kill
cancer cell like
drugs or chemotherapies that can kill
and help the release of a specific
antigen from from the cancer cell so
these uh this first
first uh set of uh
tools uh basically deals with the
with the uh the idea of providing more
antigen to the presenting cells so the
immune system can have more antigen and
work more efficiently
the second way to
to help the immune system to recognize
the cancer cell is to modulate the
interaction between the tumor cells
which is here and the effector t cells
which are here so you see that typically
this interaction is mediated by a
specific recognition of the t cell
receptor of the antigen presented by by
the cancer cells and this effector
function can be modulated either by
agonistic constant stimulatory molecule
or by antibodies that block
immunosuppressive molecule typically
in pd1
vd1 like in the system and we will talk
about this
the potential therapeutic use of these
tools later on in the presentation
and
finally there is a third way to modulate
the response of the specific tumor cells
which are here uh the specific t cells
against the tumor cells which are here
and it is the way to manipulate or
eliminate
cells of other lineage
either myeloma suppressor
cells like like here represented in the
in the corner or trx cells which t-rex
says typically inhibit on dampen the
their activity or specific anti-tumor
cells or t-cells in general and so
there is a possibility to manipulate or
to eliminate or to change the function
of this either regulatory or suppressive
cells to increase the efficiency of t
cells to recognize the specific cancer
cell and then
lead to tumor destruction so you see
there are many ways to manipulate the
immune system for an increased
recognition of the antigen presented by
cancer cells and to increase the
efficiency of specific t cells to
recognize and destroy cancer cells
um we decided to work on this aspect of
on on the immune system because we have
been working for uh for several years
with
a specific
oncogene which is called anaplastic
lymphoma kinase or alk
which was cloned about 20 years ago in a
specific category of lymphoma called
anaplasticular cell lymphoma and
in 1994 and this um alka is a tyrosine
kinase that is translocated as you see
with several different partner in uh in
lymphoma
and as a result of the translocation for
example of the most common npm ark
translocation you see that
many of the of the tumor cells in this
case lymphoma cells
they start to express the translocated
oncogenes so here is a is a an immune
reaction against the ak detecting the
fusion protein npm alk and you see that
the antibody strongly reacts
with against the cancer cells
like this one indicated by arrows but
many of the normal
cells that surround the tumor like this
one are totally negative for the protein
and this is easy to understand because
alk is normally not expressed in normal
t-cells or b-cells or lympho cells and
we say it's very low expressed in any
normal cells of the human body after
development only few neurons retain the
significant expression of the alk as a
well-type receptor on the surface
instead after chromosomal translocation
the expression of lk which is a only the
cytoplasmic domain is driven by a
different promoter mpm in this case and
the result is a strong over expression
of the fusion protein that can be
detected by antibody against alk
and you see that after the discovery of
anaplastic large cell lymphoma as the
first
tumor to have a k translocation then
several other tumor
were demonstrated to carry similar
translocation for example inflammatory
myofalastic tumor
in which about 50 they have you see a
wide range of different
ak translocation and most recently and
importantly uh nosmos cell lung
carcinoma breast cancer and colorectal
cancer as well as renal carcinoma so
another uh typical example is a normal
cell lung cancer in which
the most common translocation is the
ml for our translocation and you see
here uh depicted the
nosmos cell lung cancer with any neural
activity against with an alkane body and
you see again that
the cancer cells that
in this case
they
cover the alveoli you see here there are
all this
surface of the alveolar that are covered
by by cancer cells you see that there is
again a positive for lk i would say less
strongly that lymphoma but still
positive whereas
all the other cells like
here the stroman cells in material and
lymphoid cells they are negative for
them for the ak expression so
we thought that this window of
expression between
cancer positive cells and all the other
cells that are negative could be
exploited for cancer vaccine so to
instruct the immune system to recognize
specifically this alk protein that is
expressed by these cancers and prime the
immune system for any more efficient
anti-cancer response so what are these
very peculiar uh biological properties
of alka as a non-contagion and you might
notice that we use the word
onco antigen here because that is not a
simple tumor associated antigen but is
an antigen that express is expressed by
cancer cell but is also oncogenic
and so what are these key monological uh
properties first of all as i already
mentioned
uh in normal tissue the expression of
the wild type a k is very low and is
typically restricted for to the
some neurons
in the brain or or in some motor neurons
and so there is very very limited if any
expression in the majority the vast
majority of number of tissues
but then after chromosomal translocation
there is a selective and eye expression
by the tumor cells so as i said this
window of expression actually this gap
of expression between
between tumor cells and normal tissue is
very important to facilitate the immune
recognition of
of the cancer cell by by the specific
diesels
and these two points that follow are
also very important so there is a strong
addition of the neoplastic cells
on the alk signaling for the growth and
survival and that's very important that
goes back to the meaning of oncoantigen
so it's not just a simple antigen
expressed
by the tumor cells but is an antigen
that is required by the tumor cells for
growth and survival so the important
point of this statement is that
typically cancer cell cannot
survive without the expression of this
this antigen and that's very very
critical because most of the failure in
the past of a typical cancer vaccination
strategy
um
were probably due to the to the
selection of clone inside the tumor that
no longer express the antigen so even if
the immune system was primed well
against the antigens then some clone
escape without the expression of the
antigen anymore and there was no way for
the immune system to tackle them so in
this case with alk i would not say that
it's not possible but i would say that
is very very unlikely and uh
to confirm this point that it was a
recent study
by a group here in in boston showing
that
100 so it means all the tumor that
relapse
after specific kinase therapy i will
talk about this one later all the tumor
100 of the cases they still express lk
is an antigen so this is very important
to plan uh a strong immunotherapy
against this tube and finally also very
important is that
the egg protein itself is a is a very
very good uh
immunogenome for the immune system and
that's important because
some
antigen expressed by tumor could be
perfect or could have several
important features but then eventually
they turn out to be a very poor
immunogenics for the immune system so
even if you try to vaccinate the immune
system does not recognize those antigens
in the case of arc there are evidence
that arc is already
a spontaneous very good immunogen in
fact uh all the studies were made in in
patient with lymphoma and was
demonstrated that there is a spontaneous
ntlk immune response in this patient
that carry uh alkali orange lymphoma
like the mpm arc that i was showing
before so typically these patients show
circulating antibodies against the
diffusion protein
mostly against the out portion of the
fusion protein very little if any
against npm because npm is a
constitutive express protein that is
present in every cell so they typically
develop
antibodies against the healthcare
portion of the fusions
and this antibody the highest is the
tighter of this antibody the better is
the chronology so there is a link
between the intensity of the immune
response and the prognostic of the
evolution of the disease
but this patient they also develop
specific
t cells memory t cells with cytotoxic
potential so like cd8 plus t cells but
they also develop
cd4 plus d cells
and uh what is most important was
recently demonstrated that
the combination of this immune response
by jesus and antibody can stratify this
patient into two different prognostic
groups which means that
more or less all the patients they have
this immune response but the patient
that they have a stronger spontaneous
immune response they have a much better
prognostic
survival and endpronosis
overall
so
um i think that these are evidence in
vivo in
human experimental i would say models
that
alk itself is recognized by the immune
system as a foreign antigen is presented
and it generates antibody or a specific
t cell response
against the the protein and this immune
response already has some effect in
containing the tumor growth so we were
really
primed by this data to
plan a way to boost even further by a
specific box in the immune system to
recognize a k is an antigen in different
type of tumor and i'm going to present
data against lymphoma and against lung
carcinoma so
we decided to use the first strategy and
alk dna vaccination
in which we generated a dna vaccine that
encodes for the cytoplasmic portion of
ak exactly the same portion that is
translocated in all those fusions that i
listed about
so by this uh dna vaccination we can
inject the the dna circuits or
intramuscular in the mouse and there
will be an inflammatory reaction and
then this dna will encode for the alk
protein the protein will be
presented as single peptide to the the
immune system and a specific
cell mediated cytotoxic response uh will
be developed by by
the organism in this case all the
studies are done in the in the mouse
models so dna vaccination is very
effective and indeed we show that
a simple very simple protocol of
vaccination in which there is a one
priming
uh vaccination with with dna where
at the day zero so at the beginning of
the experiment and then a second
vaccination that works as a boosting
they are efficient enough because when
you challenge the mice
after another week so you allow the time
to build up a strong immune response
then you can challenge the mice with
all positive cancer cells and the
results were pretty
pretty uh positive in the sense that
we could show that by dna vaccination
first of all we were developing a very
strong specific immune response and the
way to test this specific immune
response
was to
evaluate the cytotoxic activity in vivo
in mice by an essay that is based on a
cfsc labeling of two t-cell populations
so here you see in uh on the left these
are cd4 t cells
okay that are wild types so they do not
express the the antigen and instead here
are normal cd4
t cells
that express the alkanetism so we
derived this t cells from our t cell
transgenic
mice that expressed the mpm fusion
specifically in these so
both this population are normal t cells
the left population is wild type and the
right population is identical except
that express lk and you see that in a
control vaccinated mice the two
population are pretty equal but in an ak
vaccinator mice there is a selective
depletion of only the alk t cells
whereas the wild type t cells here on
the left of the hot maximize they are
practically unchanged so this is a very
nice essay
to demonstrate in vivo's specific
cytotoxic activity against normal t
cells that express arc whereas the wild
type t cells they are untouched and you
can measure that and we measure that the
cytotoxic activity was depleting between
70 to 80 percent of the cells that we
injected so it was a very strong
activity and you can also track in the
spleen by injecting
r-positive and alka-negative t-cells and
then do a specific staining for lk and
here you see that there are
in control mice there are few cells that
are
a k-positive because this is attaining
in
vein injection so there are few t cells
that
home to the to the spleen and you can
easily recognize by specific staining
again you see the majority of the normal
splenocytes of course are negative but
in
lk vaccinated mice here on the right you
see that the number of specific t cells
only in the spleen goes almost to zero
definitely below 10 so you can also
evaluate evaluate this way then the
specific cytotoxic activity against
positive cells
and we show that
by this protocol vaccination the
protection of the mice so we first
vaccinated mice and then we injected the
lymphoma which was all positive was
really strong actually all the mice
hundred percent of the mice were
protected when when we vaccinated the
the
with a specific vaccine and
this is a
number of protections so you see that
there is no protection in untreated mice
or in mock vaccinated mice so it means
that all the mice die because of the
lymphoma no protection instead hundred
percent of protection in our vaccinated
mice and we also vaccinated with a
mutated construct that
doesn't have the kinase activity anymore
and still the protection was very high
and what is important that
uh this protection was very long lasting
because
in some experiment we vaccinated the
nights exactly the same protocol so to
the nfx in uh within two weeks and then
we we just waited for seven months and
then we challenged the mice after seven
months and you see that the protection
is still very high it's not 100 anymore
but it's still 70 so it means that
even with one single round of
vaccination you can
obtain a very long-lasting
immune protection and here you can
measure
directly inside the tumor by injection
so you see for example that we in this
experiment were injecting uh
lymphoma cells are positive lymphoma
cells in the flank and here you see
with the hero there are the inguinal
lymph node here okay instead with the
ask asterisk that is the tumor and you
see that in control mice mock vaccinated
mice you see that the tumor after seven
days is is a big as the lymph node but
then eventually grows much more and
after three weeks is a large mass of the
lymphoma cells are positive instead in
the unvaccinated mice you see again the
lymph node with the tumor at day seven
they are more or less the same size but
then eventually the tumor is completely
gone and you are left only with with the
lymph node and you can see here in the
mineralistic chemistry that uh in
smoke vaccinated controls there are a
lot of positive cells instead in the
unvaccinated there are majority of cells
are not negative react inflammatory
cells and here below you cannot see very
easily the immunofluorescence staining
here but
you can
we could demonstrate it to be faithful
that in alpacinetomize there was a
significant increase in
in cytotoxic t cells as tested by
granzyme b and performing positive cells
so there is a specific immune response
against lymphoma cells
that prevents tumor growth and this is
true also when we injected not in the in
the flank but systemically
alkaline formal cells so here in the
right there is a
an experiment in which we vaccinated
mice either with control or arc vaccine
and then we injected with our positive
lymphoma cells and you see that all the
control died very fast but most of them
are vaccinated mice were protected and
actually they they survived for a long
long time and we could also show that we
could efficiently combine
the
some current therapy for example
lymphoma are treated with chemotherapy
so we could safely combine chemotherapy
and alboxin which is this curve here to
obtain an even further increase of
survival of the mind so potentially we
show that we can combine
vaccination with with chemotherapy
and finally a little bit of mechanism
and here again is the in this case is a
tumor growth so we injected the
positive lymphoma cells in the flank
and
you see that typically control cells
they grow very well and fast here are
control cells
and if you
uh vaccinated mice and
you deplete for either cd4 or either cd8
you see that
with cdcd
at depletion that the tumor as the
control whereas with cd4 depleted which
is here uh the tumor they grow much less
so it means that the cd8 are really
required for for uh the cancer
activity the anti-cancer tt by the
immune system instead cd4 are less
important and by doing the same
experiments
in uh interferon gamma knockout mice in
perfectly local mice and in b cell
nocatomize we showed what is more
important is that interferon gamma is
totally required for this as expected
for this
immune system to react against the alk
antigen
against lymphoma cells perforin is
partially required instead the
production of antibodies which means the
presence of b cells is totally
dispensable
because
as you see here the tumor was as as
protected as well protected with or
without visa so these cells are really
non-needed in this in this strategy of
human vaccination
so what we learned from this lymphoma
studies we learned that the arc
vaccination elicits a very specific
cytotoxic immune response that
specifically target all positive cells
and that
mechanistically cd8 t cells and
interferon grama production is essential
for the vaccine to work efficiently
whereas b cells or antibody production
are dispensable
and the the vaccination is lost last
long lasting i mean up to seven months
but there was still a very good
efficiency
and the efficiency of the efficacy of
the vaccination depends on tumor burden
i didn't show data about this but
the this policy is the tumor the most
efficient is the the vaccination and the
vaccination is very strong
in prevention so there is hundred
percent of the prevention
of lymphoma grafts but is also uh
synergistic with chemotherapy is his
important allowance in logistic
chemotherapy in a therapeutic protocol
over until informal vaccination
okay so in in the second part of the
talk we switch from the lymphoma model
to another type of
rearranged cancer which is a
nosmall cell lung cancer and
nonsmall cell and cancer rearrange for a
cave become a very uh
hot topic recently uh in the cancer
field because uh
the was the first
chromosomal translocation recognized in
lung cancer uh and one still of the few
there are a few other clones but this
was the first one and you see that this
translocation again like in lymphoma
fuse is typically the ml4
gene different axon you see that the
length of the ml4 fusion can be
different depending on the
on the
different type of translocation but the
alkal portion
in this fusion is
always
almost identical there are very very few
amino acids in changes and even if you
uh
study
different type of translocation like the
tfg arc or other type of translocation
which are rarer
still again the translocation happened
to be exactly the same
in all
lung cancer patients
and which is exactly the same as in the
lymphoma patient that we just showed
before
so we decided to to try to vaccinate
this mice but of course we first needed
a model so we will build up a model of
lung cancer expressing the most typical
uh translocation which is mf4 arc and
also second model expressing
the
rarer tgfr
and
the specific expression in the land was
achieved by
introducing the fusion protein under the
promoter of the
spc species the surfactant protein c
which is expressed by the alveolar type
2 lung cells and you see here by by
quantitative pcr reaction that
only lung really expressed significantly
amount of the ml4 arc fusions where most
of the other organs were negative
and importantly the levels of expression
by western blot
either in the ml4 arc transgenic here or
in the tfgr transgenic here they were
quite similar to the
expression level in human cancer here on
the left there are
two
human cancers line derived from
human lung cancer and you see the
expression of these two fusions the mf4
arc is the highest and the tfg is
shorter but is is comparable with the
transgenic expression
and also by
by messenger and expression we
demonstrated that the level in our
transgene of the fusion is comparable to
the the expression in cell lines and of
course also in primary tissues
so
we thought that this model was pretty
good and indeed these mice they develop
quite fast after four months they
started to develop tumors in the lung
here you see this mass that are much
more clear and white compared to the
pinky
lung parenchyma and you see that by
histology there were multiple tumors
here that would turn out to be
uh quite strongly positive by okay but
again you see that the expression level
of alk in this tumor is comparable to to
the human tumor uh you see here is is a
human nose muscle and cancer you see
that
sometimes in human patient the
expression could be lower but in many
cases this is the range of expression
and you see that in in the mouse we had
a similar level of expression and uh the
beauty of this system was that
we could follow up the tumor development
directly in the lung in living animals
by doing
mris which is a nuclear magnetic
resonance so you see here that after two
months
there are a few tumors appearing in the
lungs here these white spots okay
and after four months like in in the
astrology picture now that the tumor are
much more they are different masses they
are confluent and eventually the the
mice die you see the survival curve of
both transgenes
uh you see that 100 of the mice
died between uh
60 weeks of age with a
mean
survival of about 35 weeks
so we thought that this was a good model
to test
ak vaccine against like cancer so we
decided to go with the vaccination again
in these cases since these are primary
tumors and not graft we decided to do
three round of vaccination
and the
important thing is that before the first
round of vaccination
we did an mri to score that number and
the tumors before
treating the animals so we could
really group correctly the mice
and
after the second
the first boost we were doing a
cytotoxic individual essay like in the
lymphoma cells and then we were
following up mice with
at least three rounds of mri over time
to check for the
number of tumor and the size of the
tumor growth and you see here that the
cytotoxic activity was very strong so
here mice
vaccinated with a controlled plasmid you
see that there is a less than 20 percent
cytotoxic activity probably due to
spontaneously uh cytotoxic activity
against the other protein but after
vaccination we really could boost up the
cytotoxic activity again back to more
than 80 percent like in in the lymphoma
model so we are very very pleased to see
this strong boosting of the specific
response in lung cancers
and we check and measure by mri the
development of tumor and we could show
that
in
in vaccinated mice here in black the
number and also the size of tumor was
clearly reduced by the vaccination as
compared to control which is this curve
here so you see there is a huge
difference in number on neoplastic fossa
and also the survival was clearly a
standard between
between the the two uh either control
vaccinated hearing white or the
arc vaccinated mice and you see that
there was a significant shift of
survival we did not cure the mice but we
had to to take into consideration that
as i showed here before in this
transgenic system there are really
really
several tens even
hundreds of tumors that develop over
time so it is conceivable that the
immune system can tackle them at the
beginning but eventually over time it is
overwhelmed by the new tumor they keep
growing if you see in this
mri you see how many tumors they really
fill up the the lungs in four months so
in this condition the immune system is
very difficult to act
so but still even in this condition the
gain of survival was very very very
significant
and when we observed that the tumor
by histology immune to chemistry
we could clearly detect an increase of
t cells effector t cells inside the
tumor so here you see control vaccinated
mice in which the tumors in the lung
are are quite big and large
and if you stain for cd3 so for the
presence of t cells inside the tumor you
see that there are very little cells
spontaneously present inside the tumor
but after vaccination you see first of
all the the tumor size is much smaller
and second you see also the color
changes because the tumor is filled up
or very small dark
cells which are of course t-lymphocyte
because they are strongly positive for
cd3 and you can count them you see that
there is a huge increase of cd3t cells
inside the tumor so this really means
that
we vaccinated the mice in the muscle in
the leg and this specific t cells they
travel in the blood streams they go up
to the lung and they recognize the
presence of the arc antigen in the lung
tumors and they start to the cytotoxic
activity and kill the tumors so we
really thought that it was the
demonstration that these cells were
attracted
by the cancer cells and they were
very active but
as a downside effect of the alboxin we
also observed that
together with effective t-cells we were
also increasing t-rex cells t-rex cells
can be
clearly stained by fox p3 which is a
nuclear staining you see here all the
t-rex cells that populate the tumor
whereas in control only few t-rex cells
so
by tumor vaccine we could
uh increase the number of effector t
cells but also t-rex cells in the tumor
so we decided to
uh go back to these strategies so to
deplete
t-rex cells remember this cartoon that i
showed the very beginning so the deplete
t-cells
can see if we could boost the
vaccination and indeed we could because
uh
when we were comparing vaccination alone
which is here this is a longer time as
if the one that you see before with a
protocol that combined vaccination and
depletion of effector t cells you see
that that
the combination of vaccination and
effective t cells were more sufficient
in
preventing tumor growth and also there
with a further gain in in survival so
this is a way a potential way to boost
the cancer vaccine against that but
you might know that one of the major
breakthrough of the recent the past two
years against the ul positive tumor
that's why there is a very hot topic uh
is that this type of tumor can be very
very efficiently treated at least for a
certain window of time by a specific
kinase inhibitor which is called
critzotinib and these are recent
publications that show that
really creates autism is effective here
is a human case in which you can see by
mri uh or by tc scan this uh
this tumor infiltrated the lung and
after christopher this tumor almost
completely disappears so this treatment
is very powerful the problem with this
treatment is that over time a crisotin
is no longer working because the
resistance is happening and we should
talk later why this resistance is
happening so eventually
the
and
so there is a there is a gap of window
uh in which this uh uh alkh inhibitor is
efficient which
lasts for about six to nine months but
eventually after this ghetto window the
tumor comes back and eventually the the
patient will die
so we decided to use this ghetto window
in other words model so first of all we
checked if the the mice were sensitive
to chrysotonine
and if chrysanthemum could be combined
with safely with vaccine so the first
experiment we were combining as you see
here chrisotiniba in the middle of the
first and second round of dna
vaccination to see if the crystalline
treatment was affecting the response of
the immune system and the answer was no
because uh
you see here the control and when you
combine a vaccination with treats other
than you see that you get as much as uh
good cytotoxic activity as the vaccine
alone so crystalline it could be safely
combined with
without vaccination and next we wanted
to test this combination in vivo and
mice so
if you look here at the the left panel
here you see in a critotin treated mice
you see that at four weeks of age
some tumors they start to develop here
indicated by an arrow you treat them
with krixoten and they completely
disappear
but when you stop the
treatment with critzotin and we did that
to mimic the relapse of patient under
credible treatment so when when we
stopped giving crediting to the mice
eventually the tumor relapsed exactly in
the same position and new tumor came and
came up
but importantly when we did the same
protocol but we added
uh arc vaccination now you see that
the tumor they start
for weeks we treat weak resulting this
is pre-treatment we treat with
exhausting tumors disappear you see
there are no longer tumors here and the
still after 16 weeks the tumor because
of the vaccination they are no longer
back
so eventually they they come back later
on you see here from the curve so as 16
weeks there are still
almost no tumor there but eventually
they start to come back after 20 weeks
and then follow up but uh the difference
between the christopher alone is is
pretty clear and once more we could
extend survival in this combination of
treatment with alkynide and
vaccine so we really thought that
this is potentially
a good way to to combine the standard
treatment now or or a future standard
treatment for all positive
cancer which is cryptozone inhibitor
with an arc box
next we decided to
try a different type of combination
because very recently last year
there was some evidence that some
antibody that controlled the immune
checkpoint could be effective against
lung cancer and what is the immune
checkpoint so now we are acting in this
point of the immune reaction in which
effector t says they recognize cancer
cell but the activity of these effector
t cells can be changed or modulated by
some
receptor which are called ctla4 or pd1
so if you give antibodies that block
this receptor which are inhibitory
receptor you can further boost the
activity and the effector function of
these cells
and uh so here is the cartoon in which
you see that after t cell recognition
there there are early inhibitory signal
like ctl4 or late inhibitory signal and
you can really uh block this inhibitory
scene along t cells by the use of
specific ct left for antibody or
anti-pd-1 or pd1 ligand antibody so
that was uh tested in in these type of
studies that i showed here and they
showed that there is some efficacy about
15 20 percent of response also in lung
cancer so our idea was why we do not
combine
alk vaccine arc inhibitor and this type
of
immunotherapy immune checkpoint therapy
to see if we can further have
more efficient cancer
immune therapy and that's what we did
first of all we show that
uh our tumor so this is an alkyne for
our transgenic mice
uh compared to another model of egfr
mutatomites egfr is a typical mutation
also in lung cancer of keras mutated
mice again keras is a typical mutation
lung cancer and we were comparing the
the expression of pd-1 ligand on the
surface of this cancer cell and we
showed that the altima they express on
average more than egfr and chaos tumor
so these were the basis to use a antipd
one ligand and pd-1 antibody to block
this immune checkpoint and
the combination was by
combining uh both an alkyne inhibitor in
this case it's not resulting in style
but it is in the same the mouse system
it's an equivalent alkyne inhibitor we
are doing the same experiment with
criteria now with this immune
checkpoint antibodies
in our protocol vaccination and and
these are preliminary data but the
response was positive so at the
beginning there were tumor the tumor
went down because of the alkyne
inhibitor treatment so this is the
decrease of size of tumor because of the
arc inhibitor here
and then the
we stopped giving the treatment we like
inhibitor and we were following up
either vaccination alone in this case or
vaccination plus immune checkpoint
blockade and you see that
this combination is more efficient
vaccination and new checkpoint is more
efficient
in preventing the the tumor
relapse in the same site
okay the last part of the talk the last
i will say five to seven minutes will be
on the
resistance mechanism uh to arc inhibitor
in in lankans so
there was uh almost immediate evidence
by several papers that as i anticipated
before
um
the arc inhibitor specifically creates
zotting but that's true also for a
second generation inhibitor that alkene
inhibitor they are very very effective
at the beginning for several months but
then eventually the tumor grows back
because of several mechanisms or
resistant to alkyne inhibitor and this
resistance are clear i would say in at
least that 50 maybe
60 percent of of the cases in which
there is either another amplification so
the fusion product the translocation is
amplified so you require more inhibitor
to treat
or single point mutations okay i will be
more specific later or the bypass
activation
of other uh molecules in particular
other uh tyrosine kinase receptors that
can bypass
the shadow of the arc as a tyrosine
kinase and compensate for for his
shutoff so uh there is also of course a
large number of tumor in which still the
mechanism isn't clear
so we wanted to to
focus because uh
in the arc amplification case as well as
in this bypass amplification as i said
before in 100 of the case the arc
expression is retained so the vaccine is
going to work it's predicted to work as
well but what about lk mutation because
alk mutation they really
change we can go here they really change
the structure of the out domain so they
can really change the immunological
property of a k as an antigen expressed
by by the cancer cell so if now lk is
mutated it can produce different peptide
and be no longer recognized by a wild
type vaccine
and you see that the list of mutation is
quite long many of these mutations were
detected in lung cancer but also some
mutations in lymphoma and uh in
inflammatory myofalvastic tumor or or
neuroblastoma and you see that there are
several mutations that could potentially
change the immunological property of ak
is an antigen in the tumor so we decided
to test few of them
mainly the most common one which are the
1174 the 1196 and 1156 these are the
most commonly find mutations in
resistant cases of lung carcinoma and
other type of tumors and you see for
example the 117
96 mutation affects an amino acid that
is in the pocket that binds critzotinis
so when this amino acid is mutated
crisotomy is no longer able to bind
efficiently the the kinase domain of ak
so does not work anymore
so we decided to test this mutation by
this essay so we took a syngenic bulk c
line which i'll call s14 and in these
cell lines which are called negative
we
express either an empty vector which is
here only with the gfp as a reporter to
check the the percentage of expressing
cells and then we transduce these cells
either with the wild-type ml4 arc of the
three most common mutation the one one
five six the one one seven four and the
one y ninety six so and you see that the
level of expression
in this transducer line was pretty good
and actually equivalent between the wild
type and the mutated ones and i would
say
very similar to the expression level in
human cancer line so again here is the
our referential expression for and for
arc in human cancer so what is happening
when you use the system then you take
these cell lines and you can inject in
the in the tail vein
um
and then these cell lines will ohm in
the lung and will be grafted and
generate
several uh hundreds of tumor in the lung
so
in
tumors vaccinated with either control
or
alk vaccine if we were injecting cells
without the expression of so these are
as 14 cells
just introduced with the gfp positive
vector so there is no alk in these cells
and either control mice or vaccinated
mice you see there was no difference of
course because the antigen is missing
from from from the cells so now there is
no difference between control and
vaccinated but if we were expressing a
arc in the in the grafted cells now the
difference is huge you see that control
cells they still
grow pretty strongly about 200 tumors
in in 14 days but in our vaccinated mice
now the number of tumors is minimal
there are actually very few and small
tumors that you can barely detect by by
histology so now tells that the alvoxine
can recognize the arc expressed
by the the cells and can block the the
graft and the growth of the tumors in
the lung and if we do the experiment
with the three different newtons as i
said before we got exactly similar
results uh in which the other vaccine
was able to block almost completely the
growth of this mutant in the lung and
this is going to tell us that most
likely this arc vaccine is going to be
active and very efficiently also against
that mutated arc tumor that developed
after critically treated in human
patients so we think that
and i'm going to the final slides
in which i summarize the points that
alk elicit a stronger immune response
also against lung cancer cells reduce
tumor growth
and then can be combined with alka
inhibitors can be combined with immune
checkpoint antibodies and importantly is
active against cryptotiny resistant
mutants and finally this is the final
slide in which
uh we think that this could be
potentially
the future therapeutic strategy in which
we have any other positive tumor there
will be a first phase of the bulking of
the tumor by chemotherapy or alk
inhibitor plus other type of inhibitor
in the window response we can now treat
the
the patient with an alt vaccine maybe
with a combination of immunotherapy
check the efficiency of the response in
terms of cd8 cd4 and eventually antibody
response even if these are dispensable
we show before and then eventually boost
again the patient if the vaccination was
not efficiently or follow up and
eventually in case of relapse there is
still chances to treat a patient with
second line chemotherapy or different
type of alkynymeter and eventually do
again the vaccination so we envision
that this could be a potential
therapeutic strategy for our positive
tumor
so uh here are the acknowledgements uh
most of the work were done
both in uh in my lab here in the boston
children's hospital at harvard medical
school and also some of the work
actually a good part of the work in the
university of torino in italy from which
i come from and of course so many of
these data needed the help of clinicians
at the donna farber kensington institute
of the boston children's hospital as
well
so
now i think
i thank you for listening and
i close my presentation here
i would be happy to answer some um some
questions that if you want to pause me
and
and thank you very much
so maybe while i'm waiting for some
questions if there are
i i go to the
the final slides i guess which
is a reminder that
if you want to obtain
continuing education credits you can go
to this website that is listed here
and there will be specifically
question and answer for
this part of the talk to get this this
credits from this presentation
you